now the question is well why is this the
important idea for how to win this game
very simple actually and by the end you
started to get quite good at it
even if you didn't you're unable to
articulate and you start to get an
instinct for why and intuition for why
certain numbers would work the win and
others will not so the question how I'm
going to phrase to you is how can we
represent the samples best how can we
show all the outcomes you can have let's
just give a quick example okay if you
were just rolling one die okay there are
only well how BIG's the sample space for
1.6 and because this is a small number I
can literally just list out what the
options ah there you go
there's the sample space as a list
that's important okay
listing out is really good because then
you can see everything in front of you
and you can work out exactly what's
happening but when you go just from we
have to do is add one more dime right it
becomes more complicated because this
die has six possibilities and this one
also has six and they're independent of
each other okay so with white diamond
with one die okay that's six
possibilities when you have two does
this is interesting if we list them out
you will find don't forget there's blue
and green right there's much more than
1200 okay next up let me show you if I
say well okay here's the blue ones and
here's the well anyway there's the green
one okay let me start listing them okay
suppose the blue one is a one okay you
can get a 1 over here
get a 1 and then a 2 1 and then 3 1 and
then a 4 1 and then a 5 1 and then a 6
but I got six possibilities right that's
all the different things a green can be
so now what should I do to get
have a look at the balloon one let's put
it to there and then I can keep going 1
2 3 you get the idea now by the time I
get to the end of this column I've
already got lists out 12 possibilities
but there's more it's more look I'm
missing all of the threes and fours and
fives and sixes now two things two
things first that means that there are
not six or twelve possibilities how many
are there really there are 36 two days
because one day has six and the other
die has six it's six times six or eight
six square if I had three dice it'd be
six cubed and I know that's those yeah
yeah different problem now you can see
with this low but no problem list it
that's fine with this no but well your
two issues number one it's just gonna
take a long time to write okay number
two you might forget one if you don't
land out in a logical order
okay so listing as it turns out is not
necessarily the best way to represent
your sample space let me show you a
better alternative kind of kind of that
tends to be more useful in statistics
here I'm trying to work out probability
which is related but different make a
little subheading for yourself this is
called a dot diagram okay
now raising hand who's heard of this
place before doesn't matter if you
remember what it is I just wanna see any
familiarity all right great hands down
here's what a dot diagram looks like I
will pull out my colors this time okay
we've got two ties and instead of
listing them downwards like this I'm
going to list them in different
directions okay I'm gonna go
horizontally and vertically like this
I'm gonna have my blue possibilities of
the top and then I'm going to write my
green possibilities down the side okay
so like I was saying before right the
green dye can be one
three four five or six blue dye can also
be one two three four five or six okay
now here's where the name of this comes
in right when you have it represented in
a grid like this okay you can represent
all of the possibilities by saying
although see this one one it represents
so I'm just gonna Pratap there that
represents one possibility one for this
and one for that I've got another
positive here here here and I can put a
dot for each one and then read off for
example if I put dots out here I can
look at this thought and say look at
corresponds to a green 3 and a blue fun
so I'm going to count up 36 dots like so
this dot diagram here is useful in that
it shows us all the possibilities but
it's not very descriptive so we're gonna
upgrade this a little bit the reason why
I showed you this is so you understand
where the name is coming from okay
but we can put more information on here
because what happens right when I
actually rolled this and Robert and
suppose you saw two ones there you
actually don't think of it as two ones
you just think of that as a zero yes
that's the important bit about it so
here on this dot on top of that spot I'm
gonna write zero that's what these two
together would mean that's the result
now that's not the only zero there is it
there are other results that will give
you zero because you played and you felt
it whereas cafeteras I could put it on 2
& 2 3 & 3 like I can keep going Cana in
fact there's a diagonal traced out by
the Zebras is it anywhere else any other
combination of dice that can give me a
zero that's it isn't it that's it now I
can have a look at the other numbers
yeah
well okay almost let's finish this
diagram okay and this will show you the
answer okay those are the zeros what do
you think is the one people next thing
to put it at once
we're all the ones gonna go good so for
example here if I roll the tuna one
that's a one but if I roll long one in a
two that's also one and you can see the
pattern continuing if I've got a three
and two that's a one a four and A three
a five and a four and with that a six
and A five
there are all ones and there's a
symmetry to it right because the dice
the same I'm getting the ones up here as
well your stand to see the pattern
aren't you we're with the twos go just
keep going just keep going right 3 and
1/4 and 2 5 and 3 6 and 4 and the
equivalent on the other side my diagrams
a bit shutting sorry you get the idea I
still have fries to put in have a look
this is the key to winning this is the
real key to winning right the
probability of a 0 right what's the club
duty is here well we remember the
probability is favorable outcomes over
sample space right well there are 6 ways
to get a 0 and there are 36 total
outcomes so there's not a 6 after your
homework what I want you to complete is
I want you to work out what all these
are as fractions and also as percentages
I happen to know them a 6 is about 17%
what's a post probability of 2 or 3 or a
4 etc and we will discuss it tomorrow